- [Kelly] Oh, you look cool as hell.
- Thank you.
- You're so cool. Oh my God.
How's your new year going?
- Good.
- Yeah?
- Really, really good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well, last time we talked about
you don't make resolutions,
you make like dream lists, right?
- Yes, I do, yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay, do you
have those yet? Do you?
- A couple of them, but I
tend to try and keep them
to myself, so I tick them off as they go,
but one of them is to finish my album.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I've been working on that.
- Oh, do that for me, please. Yeah.
- I'm on it. I promise.
- Just specifically, selfishly, yes. Yeah.
- I've got like things
that I really wanna do
and travel and places that I wanna go to.
So it's all of that, yeah.
- I love it. First you were like
I don't really like to tell people.
And I was like is that
about accountability?
- Well, yeah, because it's also like
well, you know, I want people,
I make these lists and
I keep them to myself
and they're like a secret
checklist for myself.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't necessarily need accountability,
but I go, 'cause I keep going
back to them to read them,
to make sure that I have it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But there's this weird sort of like
if I tell people, maybe
it won't come true.
- Yeah.
- [Cynthia] Type thing.
- Oh, a little superstitious.
- [Cynthia] Yes.
- I'm like that too. Yeah.
So we're celebrating music's
connection to civil rights.
So who were your social
musical inspirations?
- Nina Simone and Aretha Franklin.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, good.
(audience clapping)
- When I found out, actually
whilst I was learning about
both of them, 'cause I sing them a lot.
I sing their music a lot,
is that Aretha was inspired
by Nina Simone and she ended
up doing a couple of the songs
that Nina Simone had on her
albums. "Young Gift and Black."
- Yeah.
- You know, and, and
obviously Nina was very much
in the civil rights Movement.
Her music was about that
at some point and they
sort of met in the middle.
And both of those women are
huge inspirations for me.
- Yeah, definitely. It's
interesting 'cause nobody thinks
about it, but one, what
was like the first time
you heard Aretha? Like the first question.
- I think I was, I wanna say
it was maybe 10 years old.
- Okay.
- In my mother's car on the way to school.
And I think it was "Chain of Falls."
- Yeah. I think mine was around 13
and it was "Respect" or "Chain
of Falls." It's one of them.
- [Cynthia] One of them.
- Can't remember which one.
But I just, there was something
different about her voice.
- Isn't it just like-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It just sort of like hits you?
- Like in the right, in the solar plexus.
- Like just breaks you.
- [Cynthia] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And the tone. But nobody
really talks about this.
But she actually did cover
quite a bit of music.
- Yes, she did. Yes she did.
- Like that was a lot of her career,
which nobody really talked
because I feel like that's
maybe what influenced me to do,
like covers all the time.
- [Cynthia] Yeah.
- Because I love it so
much and I love genres.
- She had this wonderful
magical way of making any song
you may have heard that
belonged to someone else,
sound like it was already written for her.
- I thought that.
- And they were just a
stepping stone to get to her.
- So when I was a kid,
I would listen to her
and I was like, oh, I love her saying,
they're like, well, you
know, that's a cover.
Like, they did that originally.
I was like, wait, what?
- [Cynthia] Yeah, "Respect" is a cover.
- And I was like, that's what I'm saying.
I never knew like all those,
I ended up finding that out
and I was like, oh, I didn't.
- Oh, didn't know.
- [Kelly] Gosh. Yeah.
- Right. Special.
- Nobody wanted her to cover the song.
- Oh, no, no.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause then it was gone.
- [Cynthia] You lost it. Yeah.
- It was not yours anymore.
- Yeah.
- But do you hear from young fans,
like who've inspired you
as they inspired you?
- Young fans who have inspired?
- Yeah. Like how Nina
and Aretha inspired you?
Do you hear of young fans?
- [Cynthia] Me inspiring them?
- Yeah. Absolutely. What?
- Oh, I mean, I hear it. I do hear it.
And it always is a little bit overwhelming
'cause I feel like I've just begun.
You know what I mean? I feel
like I still have much to give
and hopefully more to learn as well.
- Yeah. But you're already so incredible.
- Thank you for saying that. Thank you.
- You're literally like in
my in ears, we sang together.
(audience applauding)
I've never, you have a
flawless transition voice.
Like you transitioned to
every different octave
of your voice, flawlessly.
- Thank you.
- It was intimidating as
hell to sing with you.
- No! Come on now.
- I was like-
- It is. It's one of my
favorite things I've ever done.
But just to hear you in
my in ears is a blessing.
You are so good.
- Thank you very much for saying that.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Well, I'm not lying.
- You're incredible. I mean
that your voice is astounding
and I know you're not lying
'cause you don't have to.
- I would not say it. Yeah. And you are.
I literally, I think
Jesse and I was talking,
I was like, well, that's
what a singer sounds like.
Yeah. I was like, wow.
Well, speaking of fans,
so we came across this video,
(audience applauding)
Cynthia singing on the street.
So let's see it and hear it.
♪ I'll march my band out ♪
♪ I'll beat my drum ♪
♪ And if I'm fanned out ♪
- So good.
(audience applauding)
- Funny girl. Obviously.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love funny girl.
- So that says eight years. Yeah.
I love that whole music world.
But what happened there?
How did you just start
singing that? I love you.
- Well.
- You're just like,
you know what I think? I feel like.
- We're in the middle of the street.
I bumped into him in
the middle of the street
and he asked me to sing something.
I think he must have heard
me sing it one time before.
And he was like, can you
just do a little bit of it?
Can you just? And so I
was like, okay, sure.
I don't mind any opportunity
where I could make some music.
That's what I'm gonna do.
- Oh, I don't either. Yeah.
People always, that's
like, people come up to me
and be like, oh, I don't know
if you want me to talk
about American Idol.
I'm like, hell yeah dude.
That's like why I'm here. Yeah.
- It's also like, there's this you know.
(audience cheering)
- You're gonna care when
they don't want you to sing.
- That's the thing.
- Yeah.
- It's like, I think the
wonderful thing about that,
I knew it would bring him such joy
and he's such a joyous
energy and I wanted.
- And you made his day.
- It was so awesome and
I was having a great time
and people across the street could see it.
Like, it was just fun.
- And you're reminded right,
of like why you do it.
- Do it in the first place.
- How you fell in love with it.
- Yeah.
- Those are important moments.
New film is called "Drift."
(audience applauding)
You can see it in theaters
nationwide. February 16th.
Today we're celebrating social movements
that music has touched or inspired.
So even in our personal lives,
we use music to set the tone
for whatever kind of mood we're in
or whatever's going on our lives.
So what's on your like, latest playlist?
Like what's inspiring you?
- Latest playlist.
Oh, there's a song by a
new artist called "Manana."
And it's called "You First."
- [Kelly] Ooh, that's, I like the title.
- Oh, it's brilliant. It is
about, I guess this is a couple
that might have broken up and he says,
I'll do this if you do that first.
So I'll stop saying, I'll stop joking.
'Cause you don't like my
jokes, but you stop first.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or I'll smile for you.
- [Kelly] Who's gonna make the move?
- Who's gonna make the move first?
- Yeah.
- And I think it's one of
the most beautiful songs
I've ever heard.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- Again, the new movie is called "Drift."
- Yes.
- So kind of tell us what it's
about. Who's your character?
- So it's about a young
lady called Jacqueline
who is displaced because
of the war in Liberia.
And she finds herself alone in Greece.
And she's, you follow her
just trying to put the pieces
of her life back together,
you know, it's tough for her.
But she tries to make
every day the next day.
And she meets a tour guide
who is sort of in her own way
also trying to put her life back together.
And they find friendship within each other
and something in the other
person breaks Jacqueline open
and she finally can begin to heal. Yeah.
- I love that 'cause it also
expresses like the seasons
of friendships and people that
come in and out of your life.
- [Cynthia] Yeah.
- And I feel like people come in and out
for different reasons.
- [Cynthia] Yeah. For reasons.
- Ah, well here's the thing.
"It would be" is the song
that you and who wrote it with you?
- Laura and Vula, we
co-wrote song together.
- Oh my gosh. I was
telling her in the break,
I was sent this song while
I was out in New York
just running errands and doing stuff.
And I teared up, I cried. I was like,
this is one of the best songs I've heard
in a very long time.
Like, it is so beautiful.
(audience clapping)
The production is so beautifully sparse.
The vocal ability. You are crazy rude.
Like crazy rude.
(Cynthia laughing)
It's just insane how fluid it is.
I've never heard anything like it.
The messaging is so great
and you lift it up, you know,
you don't hide it with much friction.
You just lift up the
actual purpose of the song.
Like what was that like, the
songwriting process for that?
- I was really moved by the whole thing.
Just because Laura is
such a wonderful friend.
I think she's unbelievably talented.
And it happened because I was on a run
whilst we were shooting the movie.
And I make playlists
for the movies that I do
or the TV shows that whatever.
Just so that I can find
myself in the the space.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I put one of her songs
on my playlist called "Father."
And as it was playing, it felt like
it was the language of the piece.
It felt like it spoke the
language of the piece.
And I was like, oh my goodness,
I think I wanna write the song for this
and I wanna do it with this person.
So I text Laura and I was
like, would you please.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Would you please do this song with me?
And I sent her the material.
I sent her like clips
of the film and I sent her
the script and she said yes.
So we then took a couple
of nights and went away
and wrote together and we
vocalled it in a couple days.
And that's what came of
it. And she just was,
I guess she said she was inspired
by the water in the piece and the story
and she just got it. And I was.
- Boy did you both. Yeah.
- [Cynthia] Yeah. Yeah.
- It was, I literally
listened and I was like,
I felt like I'd never
written a song before.
(Cynthia laughing)
I was like, I was like, what
am I doing with my life?
I was like, oh my God. And
I love that by the way.
I love that. Like, when
you're inspired and challenged
by other artists, it's amazing.
My dream is for you to be
singing this on the Oscars,
like you're gonna need some other singers
'cause there's a lot of vocalists.
- Oh my gosh. Thank you for saying that.
- [Kelly] Oh man.
- Oh my goodness.
- I'm on a campaign. I'm on a campaign.
(audience clapping)
Come on Oscar people, whoever you are.
All I wanna do is introduce it.
That's all I wanna do is
introduce her on stage
and just be present while it's happening.
- Thank you.
- It's so good.
And I have to say this
too, because was your mom,
did she help you with
the character in "Drift?"
- So, yeah. When my mom and I have spoken
about some of her experiences in her youth
and when she was about 15, 16,
she was fleeing in the
Biafra war in Nigeria.
So she was.
- [Kelly] Geez.
- Charter war. And she
managed to make it out
and she was also able to get back home.
But she told me some of her experiences
about what it was like when
they couldn't find food
and when they were having
to try and find safety
and all of those things.
And she's been through it.
So just having her-
- [Kelly] That's your mom.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] And her life.
- Which is crazy.
- [Kelly] It's not like
you're watching a movie.
- She made it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She's here. Which is-
- What a superhero.
- [Cynthia] Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- She looks after her
sisters and everything.
So she had younger sisters with her too.
- Man what a rad mom.
- Yeah, she's pretty cool.
- I'd be so proud.
Edith man, once again, just
killing it for the human race.
- She just, you know. Yeah,
she asked me for an iPad.
She really, I owe her more
than iPads, that's for sure.
- Yeah. But the iPad's
cool 'cause she's a mom.
She wants you to FaceTime her on it.
- [Cynthia] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And, and Candy Crush.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Oh, I like it.
- Yeah.
- "Drift" is in select New
York theaters February 9th
and opens nationwide February 16th.
And look for Cynthia's
new song from the film,
it's called, "It Would Be."